So we spent so long talking about what CUDA doesn't guarantee,
you may be wondering what CUDA does guarantee.
There are 2 main things.
Again, recall that all the threads in the block are guaranteed to run on the same SM at the same time.
Second, all blocks in the kernel finish before any blocks from the next kernel are launched.
This goes back to our programming model diagram
where you'll remember, we had some threads running one kernel, say foo,
and then some threads running another kernel, let's say bar.
So what CUDA is promising is any threads running foo will finish
in their entirety before any threads running bar are launched.